[Music]
yeah I muted the TV and will be the
entertainment okay this is great how
much time you have I mean I can I've
done up to an hour I can do 30 minutes
it's really whatever whatever you feel
yeah 4:30 cool
yeah and that's um this is our water
sponsor this is font Asst this is a
Georgia spring water from the Blue Ridge
Mountains so trying to be professional
for you here oh we're going already
oh we're on oh we're already on we don't
have much time you know we got to go got
a catch I love that everybody saw the
backstage how this eye operation
operates you know the hustle though I
mean you've been doing comedy almost fun
I think gonna have a timer on me think I
know he agreed to 45 minutes I think
they're at 40 right now
now we know we have five minutes left
I've never done a show like that we're
actually the sitting two was even even
me saying is it alright if we're here
all that was on know whenever we sat
down is when I hit it good
hey I've been doing this if I have over
almost 160 episodes now Wow so we've
been doing this a couple years I've been
doing columns impressed by me doing the
view five times and now my Foreman for
fun even though they've been on that
long 160 episodes that's awesome
what's four impressive the view or all
the presidents you've performed for yeah
actually we're doing this the day that
George Bush he was at he was in the
audience when I performed for all the
presidents Wow yeah and Barbara Bush was
there and I was so tempted to talk about
her pearl necklace but it was not gonna
come love master you love Natalie I was
I was once in my life I refrained I zip
my lip
you know I've dealt with hecklers before
and I had audiences but never security
Secret Service would have jumped on me
I'll disappear in those kind of
situations here well I'm glad I didn't
do it but anyway yeah it's great to do
we've got we've got Ravens fans over
here are the Ravens playing the Falcons
know I do a lot of Ravens people not to
hip on to the the football anymore oh no
no I have to be I host a sports radio
show on Sirius XM now what yeah I know
with me I have too many things on my
resume already it's very confusing to
people that's what's so inspiring I
think about your career especially for
comedians cuz like you probably don't
know about this this podcast is all
about like comedy mastery and wow it's a
lot of comedians listen or like fans of
comedy that love like the how I built
this approach to the craft interesting
so what's cool about learning about you
is that even during almost 40 years and
you're showing comedians that there's
way more than just sticking you stand up
that's actually what I what you know I
meant tour a lot of comics okay I knew
that it's not my bio but Kenny Loggins
son was one of them well he now he now
tours with me and we're a works he runs
my company and he told me when he was I
was touring with Kenny Loggins actually
I was in my 20s and so exciting I went
from the little comedy club to arenas
stadiums and Broadway and it was and he
was a little 6 7 year-old kid on I want
to be a comedian like tail around I
never saw him again in his adult life
and then Kenny played a concert at my
studio production studios and Kenny was
there and he says you remember my son
Cody oh yeah he always wanted to be a
comic he goes well he's now he's now
going to be a comedian at 36 years old
they decide he's gonna do comedy and he
shows up at my place he's six foot nine
I said well there's a bit right there
uh-huh
you know I when I'm coaching people I
say you've got to talk about what you
know hmm
and I said right material about being
Kenny Loggins son because you know we
wanted to avoid it and I said there's
only six people on the planet they could
do that material your five siblings and
you yeah no one else can do that
material Buffy
Kenny Loggins son and and and it's
really unique and also six foot nine
from Brad Garrett that's about it so
he's good for the six foot nine material
that's some I fit one of my favorite
quotes is like no one can steal you know
yeah that's that's yeah that's why I
went through a period of time in comedy
where I just thought it was about making
people laugh and was about the jokes and
when when it's not organic a people can
smell it and be you end up you know it
becomes hacky or you know it's it's
copied or even stolen is you don't you'd
steal some material back in the day
right or you borrow or yeah well you
know yeah I mean that was almost that
was almost the the thing back then
though I guess to get your stage time
yeah you know I see it now and I don't
get too judgmental about it cuz I
understand it because you're you're
getting your sea legs and stuff but then
I just hit this point probably in the
mid-90s where nothing that comes out of
my mouth is not experiential gotcha that
way even if someone disagrees in my
opinion which happens a lot in life they
can't disappear they can't disagree with
my experience no that's not right no
this happened and you know you can have
your opinion on what my experiences or
the delivery whatever it is but you
can't deny someone's experience so that
it took so you starting in the early 80s
like junior of high school yeah so it
took you really did your research I did
you know that you love master we got a
no is called no doors do you know the
people that have oh my really I'm
getting a restraining order there's a
little creepy right now Wow
no one knows that that's some that's
some deep research that's research that
goes beyond when internet was around I
mean this is when I was putting
pamphlets on phone poles Jim oh yeah I
mean it was a whole I was the first one
with a fan list huh postcards and they
would I would mail them uh-huh my
schedule and events and things like that
and you know it's how I developed a
following but you know I had people
opening for me that one at stage time I
started headlining early because I did
impressions that was the other one
that's not org
annik mmm wasn't but it got me to
headliner fast gotcha so I did a lot of
impressions and I hardly do have to two
or three now but it's so different
people would open for me like Dave
Chapelle when he was 14 what yeah I was
his first headliner that he worked with
Judd Apatow he would make me little
mixtapes I still have the mixtape so he
could you know kiss my ass to open for
me in San Bernardino oh yeah it's a it's
a Whitney Cummings used to tour with me
and sell my merchandise I have the honor
of she mentioned me on a podcast on
Rogen's podcast and said I'm the only
guy that's never hit on her I was pretty
proud of that yeah I guess hey Whitney
not that I wouldn't want to was married
at the time Wow so I yeah a lot of
people are on that list and people I've
mentored there's a number of them I have
them open for me and I work on their act
with them and you know and allow them
it's kind of like microwaving a career
because yeah you're going from one
o'clock in the morning bringer shows
stand in line to now you're in front of
a in a rooms in front of great sold-out
adult audience mm-hmm so it's a great
training ground and sometimes people are
not ready for it yeah and bombing is a
big part of that so like what is I
always ask comedians on here like their
epic booze story or like one of the most
unforgettable bombs they've ever had
like I've ever had well it's for almost
40 years I know it's a lot to think of
well one always stands out is working
this is backward comedy they would put
it anywhere mmm this guy it was called
Mitchell's comedy club Joe Donato and he
made this he made a club out of a garage
and he'd like painted the windows so you
could see it was a garage door you'd see
the TV we had a double garage mm-hm and
he painted over the windows and he made
a comedy club in Palmyra New Jersey
right across the river and having a
really rough time because he would open
up the show with really filthy premise
no like he sets the show up it's like he
was I think his opus closing joke was
so I came all over the curtains all
right here's your head you know so oh my
god
so wouldn't that sets the precedent of
course you know the audience to what to
expect if you're not you know tripling
you know my dog came on the curtains or
whatever if you're not upping the stakes
on that that he set the bar
I wasn't like presents it was very
strange and audience was laughing when I
wasn't telling a joke that's going on I
see this thing on a corner of my eye I
look it's a guy humping me he saw dry
humping me like a doll gonna on a leg
he's gonna hit his face on him like like
fully into it like oh and I and it's the
only time I've ever walked offstage Oh
talking I counted I'm over at 10,000
shows now mm-hmm at least and it's the I
think it's the only time I ever walked
off did you say anything are you
literally just like oh that's it's a
full-on disrespect yeah I just felt so
violated and so I'd say that's probably
the worst situation I've ever had how
long into the set was it it was pretty
short and it was pretty yeah I don't
even know how he creeped up behind me
was that there still have the visual of
it oh my gosh yeah yeah I got his card
he's my facebook friend now of course
yeah he's an engaged follow it it's what
we're looking for now I love him to look
me up if by chance watching your show
right now I'd love to have a rendezvous
if even a club anymore was that during
the boom boom like a cocaine-fueled just
free-for-all really number of times Wow
the guy in Erie Pittsburgh I can tell
you all the club owners that were heavy
heavy into it
did my people over here I don't know if
I could talk about yeah this is a
podcast we're doing a comment it's
called hot breath if you'd like to
google it or tag us if you post it on
social media while you're behind the
scenes I might say something
objectionable cool well enjoy thanks for
hanging out the lobby is now r-rated
this is now a live podcast Craig so
we're doing the comedy boom yeah so they
would my first freebasing
look I said I'm gonna pay you I didn't
even know what freebasing was and then
it turned into crack but it was called
freebase he shows up with a blowtorch
what am i doing I was just following the
path of Richard Pryor I guess in every
single way but yeah it was it was a I
remember with Rosie O'Donnell and I
started together we're like teenagers
and we're part of this improv group and
I remember us literally counting the
comedians who were in the business you
could count them like list them because
that's how few there were and now
there's tens of thousands of comedians
who claim they are and but we at one
time we're gonna what about oh yeah yeah
yeah we made a list of all the comics
and I used to book the comedian's as
well like Eddie Murphy you know I had a
one-nighter came now for $100 from 450 I
think he was from New York and they'd
all come down to Philly and I had this
this room and yeah it was it was a
really transitional time into where we
are today with comedy but you know we
put our time in do you think we're at a
boom again I can't tell truthfully I've
stepped so far out of the business from
headlining where it's rare when I even
see who's up-and-coming or I don't watch
and I also made a decision years ago so
it wouldn't be accused of theft I don't
watch anyone yeah I watch the people
opening for me to see if they step on
any premises or whatever it is and then
and it's it's it's a tough aspect of it
because the one time I
did stop in my friend books this five
threads it's in my neighborhood
okay it's right down the street from me
and I went and I saw these up-and-coming
comics I was really fascinated you know
you can see the passion and the hunger
and you know and and I don't have that I
have a hunger of making money for kids
and I know this is what I do well yeah
you know what I mean so I'm in I do my
thing I don't I don't you know I don't
hang any more afterwards there's no
waitresses that's why I retired I retire
did one it's like nine months right yeah
you know of course you know no so yeah I
retired mm-hmm and what brought me back
really was that I didn't have a
retirement plan right and everybody like
DL Hughley is a buddy and he goes well
he'll be back he thinks it's cuz he's
still hungry he thinks he thinks I'm
back because of the ego my egos done I
don't have that drive anymore I'm not
doing it to get attention I'm not doing
it for love or what I thought was love
or waitresses phone numbers or any of
that stuff that's not why I do it I do
it now because I do like to share the
gift I've been given and developed and
then and even pass that on and be of
service to other comics so if I find one
so I found one that night who I thought
oh my god I get a discovery here I
talked to her afterwards and her name is
Zara Mizrahi and she really had that you
know I really do think that I do have
this I can pick the stars what is that
yeah well I'll get to that okay so I
said I said to her I talked to her
afterwards and she even had that
offstage okay she even had that and will
Wow and then I said I thought I had a
discovery I was going to sign her the
top management so someone else is
already founder right but now you know
she's opening for me next week and you
know we become friends she was on my
podcast and wow what a talent and she
has it and it factors are absolutely
who she is even at a young age yeah she
is and confident in that and people
smell that the second she walks on stage
they know that this is someone that has
a definitive character that has already
developed at a young age and some people
have that and some it takes them years
took me years to know that character of
what I am on stage and and off so I tell
people all the time the most important
thing is you're off stage work is
working on self and self discovery self
evolution if you can get that down you
know I've done shows but it's not only
that it's the promotion of the shows
it's doing things like this and you have
to adapt it I mean Here I am literally
you know I'm last week I'm on a national
television show Here I am literally in a
hotel lobby yes before I do my three
shows the night in Atlanta with a guy I
met last night for a minute and it's
like okay you have to adjust but it's
only me who's doing that it's not this
joke teller that's doing that uh-huh
like I know when I beep started in a
business and a lot of comics or this way
as I set me up for the joke and you and
you can but you can see in their eyes
that they know it's coming or they or
they're searching for it or forcing it
and that is I'd say take a different
direction from that it's not about the
joke writing the jokes come out of the
situations it comes out of who you are
in those situations so if we have a
funny moment if I've ever made you laugh
or anybody here who have I ever made the
line it was just completely organic
response probably never even said before
mm-hmm to the situation and that's me
doing that that's not the joke teller
comedian doing that so that takes it you
know it takes life growth and certain
people have it and some don't and and
that's what I saw in her and I see it
with some others too you know once in a
while I'll pop in or see someone or
someone sends me you know a tape and
that's rare I don't even like to do that
I just I don't want to be influenced
either I you know and it can happen
happens to the best of us so now if I
remove myself from it
now I'm only influenced by you know a
quarterback or wide receiver I watch a
lot of football now my sports podcast so
I've got a I've got a good quick release
now yeah I'll absorb people's voice like
if I watch too much even if I watch like
too much of a Dave Attell I'll like just
somehow in the back of my mind start
talking like him it's and you connect
with his rhythm so then it becomes your
rhythm as well because you like that
style you might not like my style or
someone else you might respect it or say
oh that does but yeah it's the you know
but the ones that you can really kind of
connect with hmm those yeah you get and
you can see sometimes where people
develop their comedy it's even sure you
know if there's like two or three people
in that region that have certain cadence
and a style you'll see a lot of the open
mic errs kind of you know adapt that
style or not in that style and it's uh
it happened to Philadelphia when I was
growing up a lot of people had this you
know a very similar thing and now it's
just it is me it's a heightened me that
goes onstage it's a little edgier little
angrier at times and times I pull back
on that as well it's it's a it's a
confident smile that's all throughout oh
okay I mean I I know that it works you
know the next thing that's coming you
the next thing is coming I know that it
works so has it like a wry smile
attached to it not people like
confidence I think they there in the
audience you know it's it's not like
it's not like watching a you know a rock
band where they go man he sweated you
know with comics that they well we got
him you know it's a whole different
audience because they don't want to see
you sweat now see you sweat from hard
work but they don't want to see you
sweat from nerves they do not want
anyone to see you were absolutely in
control and you said smile throughout is
almost like body laying it has involved
like what cuz that's something finding
your voice is one yeah one thing comics
struggle with and also the confidence in
the body language like what
tips you have in that direction well
again it's really it's who you are in
the world I mean there's there are some
things I could still work on like body
language I remember I went to the Tony
Robbins you know that is yeah and he's
an old friend and invited me I'm with
his big she's tens of thousands of
people it was unbelievable you guys got
it down it's like a DJ at a rave okay
you could do a guess I'm getting better
positive but I did walk out of there
with a I've never been able to this
you've never could of research I've
never said it before I have never
brought myself to it to any situation
unless I do something like that with
great posture hmm there's always and I
all and I think it's kind of the reason
I never really made it made it to the
top is there's always this little
element of me that doesn't want to be
seen I know it sounds strange - for a
comic that's been in front of so many
people but there's there's there's
almost an element that still wants to be
able to be my hotel room all day today
you know vegging out there or just you
know people I myself and have solitude
and and not expose myself so I don't
really have the greatest body language
in the world even here I'm lumping a lot
of people like you a pretty good posture
but I I don't know see I think something
was you know beaten into me when I was a
kid is you don't show yourself hmm you
don't you know wipe that smile off your
face a lot of those messages were part
of you know who do you think you are
you know I'll knock the block off your
shoulder or whatever it is it's like you
know just don't take it all the way with
your with your confidence because then
you're cocky so I don't have great body
language because of it but when I do
Tony Robbins for like two weeks I'll
walk around and then slowly the light
will slowly start to day and it's kind
of like the evolutionary chart I can
learn like the third guy yeah and yeah
it's just it's just one of those things
it's not like I think about it all
I'm or you know I could obviously switch
it up if I wanted to but part of me you
know I really I like I like humility too
that's one of the problems it not to be
political it's one of the problems I
have with Donald Trump now I can also
speak from experiences nobody gets mad
at my opinion I've experienced him in
real life you know of real life like
it's a fake life but I met Donald oh
yeah I've hung out with them in Ann's at
a green or white situation as well it's
a situation where I literally know
there's no no money either oh okay
and actually was with I the first time I
met it was Tony Robbins and I was like
Tony why did you have that guy you know
because I'll never forget it this is a
lot of people speaking and and they were
talking about rejuvenation and all these
are words and he walks all right honey
goes I have an R word revenge
I remember going wow that's your
motivation as a Tony why do you have it
and I think you know Tony's like he's
you know whatever it was whatever the
answer was I remember thinking that
that's not who you are Tony so I was a
little taken aback by it but that he
would have Donald Trump as one of his
speakers again this is before politics
so take it away with you liberal you
Holly just take the label away for a
moment if you are bothered by this this
is my experience mm-hmm so my experience
is he brags about himself all the time
and and the ends up it ends up you know
turns into lies and it turns into
boasting and these are all the things
I've been taught to go the opposite way
of that which is incongruous with the
business that I'm in because I'm
supposed to promote myself exactly I'd
rather you call me a master the me call
me a master or you saying I saw your
show last night and this is what the
show was I'd much rather that I prefer
that one hundred percent than me saying
hey I'm great I can't even imagine the
words coming out of my mouth you know
and in that way that he does it and and
the bottom line is vote form or not I
don't resonate with that type of person
and yet many of those my peers made it
like that
that mindset it's the mindset of tunnel
vision I'm gonna I'm gonna just keep
going I don't care who I hurt who I
offend I'm gonna use people along the
way you know again you see his track
record and I can I don't want to name
comics but there are comics that have
done that that I grew up in the business
with and they if everybody people ask me
like what do they have in common the
ones who make it that's what they have
in common
it's an undying belief in themselves and
they go about life where it's it's it's
an arrogance that it's it's it's it's
non empathic it's not compassionate it's
just about them and feeding that ego
that is so gigantic and if that's what
it takes to make it I don't want to make
it I'm putting make it in quotes
obviously I would subjective yeah it is
subjective other people see my career
like oh my god are you kidding me yeah
you know but then there's others that go
who with who the hell are you they have
no idea who I am you know so yeah I
never went to the top top didn't get my
own sitcom when everyone else was you
know won awards but I didn't take it
further and and if I'm gonna like be
objective about it I I do think that
that's the biggest part of it is I look
at them the I call them the Trump types
uh-huh and I don't want what they have
I don't if it if that if money leads to
what I see is misery what I see is a
lack of character what I see is false
non-organic I don't want any part of
that I want the life that I now have
which is really awesome
you know what I've created it is it is
it easier to look back at that cuz like
in a moment it's like you're voting
commune of the year yeah and they're
giving away sitcoms like they're mints
community they're by the way was the
loneliest night of my life
really loneliest night of my life it was
another was another haha moment uh-huh
oh so here I thought this would be the
answer so all of those things that
motivate me Oh that'll be the answer
that will if I get that then it will
lead to the
mm-hmm and all of those that's that I
got that were the the goal if you will
not one of them was fulfilling not one
of them including communicate American
Comedy Awards you know previous winners
were Jerry Seinfeld and Ellen DeGeneres
and Jeff Foxworthy I'm going hey there's
a sitcom I'm gonna be I'm gonna do a
sitcom about a gay redneck and a show
about nothing or something you know
around to have and I did have offers and
things like that but it was the
loneliest night of my life because then
you become the target and comedians you
don't want to be on their bad side
they're the smartest people on the
planet I agree so therefore if the
comedians are the smartest they also
have the smartest heckles the smartest
criticisms you know so now it was that
night I had was alone in a limo I'm
going where do I go now I had my trophy
with me and I went to a place I don't
even go it was Comedy Store and I walked
in with my trophy and they're like
laughing at me
there was nobody coming up go away I've
never been recognized in an airport what
are you comedian Mary Burke how many
Awards all these things I thought would
happen there would open doors if
anything had closed more doors first of
all I wasn't ready and I you know like I
should win today because I Know Who I am
and and I don't need those things to
fulfill me and yeah that's the irony is
now that I'm this age and this thing
this much time out of the belt and
they're all looking for the new thing
there's no way I'd win no one of those
awards but it's so bittersweet and that
in the moment you're like oh this is a
low and now you can look back and be
like no that was a good lesson it was
that I mean now grow from but like it
you know I'm I'm almost nine years into
the game and I can look at me like oh I
want to I want to be on Conan or do
Colbert like have a Netflix special but
it's almost like I've heard this from
other comics too is like almost the
vanity goals end up just being almost a
mirage yeah they are and that's vanity
goals I guess that's what they are
mm-hmm I mean you could consider them if
you were working at a corporation you
could say oh I've advanced the
vice-president and I'm president you
could look at it as that but it's not as
standardized as office situation or any
other job for that matter and you don't
know what's coming around the corner I
have no idea you know I just keep
showing up I took a sports show on
Sirius XM and I just started a podcast
where I do it like I'll talk don't
interview my account I just try to do
keep it simple and and what's again I
used the word organic it's like what is
truly the message from underneath from
deep underneath now that all those
layers have been peeled away those
insecurities and those fears and those
difficult times that I went through in
real life as opposed to comedy that's
the real life stuff is really horrific
some of it but I'm through it I got
through I'm a survivor and Here I am now
Who am I in the world I like to be of
service to people now I like to be
loving I like to connect and these are
the things that move me into the next
direction that usually does not mean
Fame though so for younger comics
listening may be a nice a shortcut based
on your career and lessons you've
learned is to almost not almost take a
self-reflection on what you personally
want instead of maybe what other people
are getting not more of what you want
who you are who you are okay is who are
you like if you you know if we're all
talking about human potential the word
potency is in there so that means we all
have a potency that wants to emerge it
wants to fulfill itself so if you keep
tamping that down through whatever
methodologies you have it could be
through it could be through you know
cocaine could be through something
that's not in integrity because what
wants to come out is filled with
integrity is filled with you and it's
filled with
you know this great essence of light so
by the way fear of other comics being
judgmental will also prevent you from
allowing that light to shine because
we're so dark so misery loves company
yeah and that's another reason I don't
really hang out with comics it's just
this this misery fest of people there's
this there's this thing they have I
remember my friend going to it called
sit and spin and I don't really know
what it is it's contempt prior to
investigation but it sounds like you
know just people just spitting out their
their resentments hmm and it you know in
a funny way but I think that the
audiences can also smell it if you're
still in it if you see what I'm saying
if you're still in those in that
confusion and and and and in that anger
and in that rage that's you know and the
only way you're getting out is this dark
act that doesn't have much light to it
and you're just and other people who are
also darker responding to it which you
could do well with it but I think people
realize at the end of the day that you
have have some work to do and that's
this biggest suggestions do that work
however you do it you know in that
self-discovery world you know a lot of
comics are too cynical to go to a Tony
Robbins or they would hear me talking
right now even if I talked spiritually
you know I mean there's an immediate
reaction you know I had a guy on my
podcast my old roommate it was an
atheist and I said so what do you
believe in and he and he said well I
believed be good to people he'd be kind
of people I said what if that's your God
it's just a label you know if so it
being good to people I said that's more
spiritual than a lot of religious people
that I know oh you're being good to
people oh you're telling the truth
that's that's great so you're a
spiritual person
you're a spiritual human being that's
why that's what I told him I think I
talked him into it spiritual practice
because that's what he practices mmm any
likes to give laughs and joy to people I
said what another that's another great
thing it's spiritual in nature people
think you need to sit in a rock
in Sedona in a lotus position to get
spirituality we are the spirit that we
are allowing it to be freed if you will
like we jail it up you know we cynicism
sarcasm negativity and all of that you
know knocking people down all of that is
preventing us from really allowing that
if you blossoming if you will you know
we're not watering the plant another
frustrating part in doing stand-up and
there is like a spiritual connection
with the audience and that if you aren't
in the best mood sometimes your jokes
don't hit as hard because they can feel
kind of the subversion and emotion
behind your material but sometimes you
have a joke that's you've been working
it out and doing it and it's it's
working and you're killing it and all of
a sudden almost lose the you lose almost
the rush the freshness of it becomes a
little stale and then you stop
delivering it is um you know excitingly
and then it almost stops working how do
you cuz let me love master how long we
been doing love master
love masters a long long time for
decades and it made my career because
people could remember that rather than
my name a lot of people also haven't
made it because they just have don't
have the right name oh yeah can you turn
you the whole brand and it's been a
spray on the UV and branding is a big
thing and there was a guy Tony Monica a
tiny little club called rooster T
feathers it was just a part of my act I
developed it actually on tour with Kenny
Loggins and oh no I developed not on
stage I developed it because I had like
summer camp I was touring with people
you tour with comics and start doing the
love-master they'll tear you know do a
character told dick jokes there's not a
comic alive that would approve of that
so I was with civilians I called mmm
touring with civilians and made them
laugh and I started doing my acting Tony
Monica says you should be the bill
yourself as the love master I started
doing that and it's a very small part of
my act
but that's what people come for it's
like a best-of it's like right the
advantages over like Springsteen has to
do Born to Run
he can't change the lyrics mmm you know
he can't do baby I'm born to trot I'm
born to jog
right he's got to do born around they
say baby it'll sing along with them
whereas I can change all the lyrics to
the love-master and keep the character
I've actually changed them up a little
bit to update them to is it comes from I
let people know there's a lot more
revealing that goes onstage anyway on
even why I do comedy those stories are
in there and now I talk about the love
master is my answer to girls who would
all use the f-word with me friend know
is the friend
mmm-hmm geeky guy and they always like
the badasses I'm give the geek a chance
baby and he's that down there oh yeah
yeah yeah no bad guy that they always
ended up with and I give them that guy
and it's crazy how some people connect
with I have a few people say it's awful
they hate that's it worst part of your
act
fine you know it's not you know
everybody's got their hits you know and
then some people like the other side of
the album what's the what's the
comparable term for that now the other
is a b-side the b-side is all I was
thinking yeah yeah I've got these other
cuts that I really enjoy right now but
they're not the best of and it's not
people aren't coming to see hey you know
how come you didn't well actually they
do that sometimes they'll say why did
you do this bit or want to do that you
know mr. Pryor had like out on the road
over the years doing low-mass he
probably some women like you probably
had to you maybe like had some groupies
you actually played love master the
entire night with would you I had one
unfortunately I came out of character
and I I ended sooner than I wanted I'm
always good the second time hilarya I
had a crazy sex story here in Atlanta
yeah I mean it wasn't like it wasn't you
know rock and roll ish but there were
times you know again they were feeding
this idea that I had of Fame that's what
you're supposed to do and I think that's
what happens just in society period was
it's a motivator for athletes for actors
for singers for producers a lot of the
producers like losery
nerdy good abuse of power and a yeah
like the Harvey Weinstein I mean it's a
perfect example of this guy you know
couldn't get laid you know but he became
famous and powerful and it's a it's an
aphrodisiac for people and but it's it's
that it's the concept that needs to be
examined and then hence dropped of I'm
going to it's its predatory but what's
the Atlanta story we want to hear it
well so oh it's really dirty yeah we've
got time and it's okay we're at 36
minutes right now so so but I mean you
can you go there with this I thought
it's like inventory type of show I mean
it's this mentor you into demented but
this is comedy you know the the good the
bad and the dirty yes all right this is
word for word truth by the way it sounds
like some letter you would send in the
pen I did tell it on one other podcast
and I never thought I'd tell it for
people you know this is not good for my
family man brand but it's all anticipate
is authenticity yes and that is the most
important thing and it is from my past
and I have learned from it but I will
tell this to actually you can just tune
out right now if you don't want to hear
something that's debaucherous mm-hmm and
predatory you can just stop you know I
hope you hopefully you've heard some
nice things and now we're gonna go into
okay we're at 38 he's stalling until the
45 minute filibustering into so it was
the old punchline okay it's over 20
years ago and I was with my friend
Stanley Ullman he was one of the guys
who would open for me and tour with me
but Stanley is not one of the young
up-and-coming comics he's an older comic
I knew back in the 80s you know bald guy
hasn't been laid since I think Carter
was in office I think he was last time
he was late but I preface that by saying
it comes into the story later so he's my
running mate if you will my wingman and
I walk offstage and there's this
beautiful 19 year old strawberry blonde
shorter young lady she goes my friend
thinks you're funnier than Jim Carrey
and she's in Playboy really I go across
the parking lot and there is this vision
five foot nine blonde unbelievable also
pulls the Playboy out of the trunk of
the car
there she is was like a lingerie episode
but it's still it she look great and I
go hey you guys want to go back to my
hotel so they said sure we got to get
rid of our boyfriends I'm going
boyfriend's pull up on a gun rack and
I'd pickup truck they got rid of him so
I had a rent-a-car and Stanley's my
running mate you know again he looks
like remember weebles it's kind of like
a weebles wobble they all fall down he's
like as short as he is like a little
heavier he can take his teeth out I mean
it's not you know anyway that's my
running mate so we were like little kids
looking in the rearview mirror
they made a left they made the right
they're really following us oh my god
they're following us so we get back to
my suite and I go into the minibar
get him drunker and so I started reading
the magazine like I'm in a chair like
this and they're sitting over there I
said yeah this is very nice you look
awesome without your clothes and and I
said how about a live version suddenly
she goes yeah sure yeah and she goes you
all know what queefing is oh why I said
[ __ ] fart she goes my [ __ ] so tight I
can queef jingle bells so momma the
clothes she is a heart-shaped strawberry
pubic situation and she gets on the
ground in a lotus position or like a
like a yoga position and out like
note-for-note
like I miss noted that just now she was
much better with her vagina than I was
with my lips trying to imitate her the
other one starts to get jealous and she
pulls her clothes off and she also has a
strawberry blonde pubic situation in a
heart it's like like they called each
other up and said what are you what are
you gonna go with tonight and she says
my [ __ ] lips are so loose I can tie him
in a knot
oh so she starts yanking on them and all
of a sudden Stanley goes she's pushing
she's missing she goes no I'm not I'm
coming she's making me come so the one
who's doing the the queefing is making
her aroused and she is wetting the
entire living room is soaking I still
think was urine Stanley in her they
insist it was it was so the other ones
in the second verse unbelievable noted
and she and she ties these she's pulling
them down she's like getting loose and
they're like Bermuda Lakes she could get
into a country club yanking on him they
were like utters and then she ties him I
said well I used to help my mom with
packages and I put my you know she ties
a knot around my finger and I was
unbelievable so now I says oh it says
here to the other one I said in your
article that you like water I said I
went the other room I filled up the
bathtub and the three of us are standing
over her this glistening naked body goes
into the tub like Daryl Hannah from
splash I was just looking at her and she
goes I could do all sorts of things with
my [ __ ] and she goes point somewhere
and then out of the water just she just
rises up and this squirt that came out
she would like fill herself up and it
just a you know those super soakers
mm-hmm yeah I pointed to Stanley's I
said how about his forehead just dome
right in the forehead maybe she gave him
a wet t-shirt so funny now I understand
I'm not really into the sexual aspect of
this although I am a little bit
but I'm on to the funniest I always love
funny first right Staley's into the sex
and he's like he's a big porn watcher so
we go into the other room and she's like
this thing is just going wherever I told
her it wherever I pointed that she'd
squirt so we go in the other room she
gets on the table a coffee table she and
the three of us the rest of three of us
are on the couch together on the couch
just watching her like a stripper and
I'm like and Stanley turns into like a
porn director cuz he loves porn he's it
support East I see him pull it out and
he starts giving directions like a
director goes yes the other one gets up
it starts board her head smacking her
and she starts going down on her
standing up whoa and he goes I'm out he
finished he finished and he walks out of
the room and now I'm left with the two
of them in the living room and the only
bad end to the story it's still a good
story I didn't do anything because I was
just starting to date someone whoa yeah
and I thought what I did was more of a
director like I could have done Oh
master director and I would direct the
each scene and but I didn't direct the
scene with me in it so I never
participated and I regret it now not
going all the way the other relationship
ended with the girl you were sacrificing
for act three so anyway that's I can't
believe you got that out of me but I've
lost all credibility I was either
laughing at the front desk how can you
not well anyway so that was one and I
you know I had my times that were crazy
but now to go back to the spiritual self
mm-hmm all of those times again like
comedy and those you know goals you have
you know threesomes and craziness and
stuff like that none of those are
they're worth just a story today you
they're not there wasn't I didn't grow
from them I didn't have the greatest
moments I remember threesomes I'm so
codependent I'm going oh if I if I you
know if one satisfies me and then the
other one's gonna be feel left out right
or not as good about herself right she
shouldn't feel good that Shepard
recently but still but so there's
there's that element I might I think I'm
different than a lot of people but
anyway it's just who I am
and so the great moments the pockets of
joy for me are like these in the moment
moments like I had a lot of them are
spontaneous but they come from you know
my own source I hope this guy not helped
him I this guy his whole family are fans
and that's another thing I really like I
have generations now it's real yeah I
came last night was Eagle Eagle Scouts
under 16 whoa and a kid really you know
couldn't believe you know Atlanta here
and the father and their neighbors and
that's really that's a really great
aspect of it so this is gang of Fame 45
right now - okay but I don't want to cut
you off what do you guys so so uh we're
okay we're okay
yeah I my shows in a half an hour it's
all right I don't have this is my prep
we hit the checkpoint
I'm getting my I'm getting my voice
ready for this real shows the only place
I do three shows and I do an hour and a
half show I know
yeah your opener does like seven minutes
yeah exactly so thanks for that thanks
for being willing to go in overtime here
yeah so this guy his dad is on the way
out
older guy and I said can I visit your
dad and and their wealthy family the guy
kept saying what can I get you what do
you want I go I don't want anything if I
can bring joy to a guy who is definitely
a fan they've seen me dozens of times if
I could break joy he goes well he might
not know who you are he didn't know his
daughter yesterday okay didn't know what
I was getting into I thought I was go to
the hospital but he was already home
with hospice type care and I walked in
and a guy lit up and the guy goes Oh
good it's the love-master turns it was
nursed you know this is the greatest
comedian and I made him laugh I told him
dirty jokes cuz one no way out they
don't care for ya
and I tried out new love master lines on
them and man I was one of the great days
of my life was watching this guy light
up he's on the way out and then and then
I said hey listen my dad's never said
happy birthday thought I with my parents
don't speak to me for years I mean it's
not yours yeah never said your mom never
said she loves you and your dad yeah
cult leader and yeah yeah and it's it's
a it's a real mess
so he'd answer and it's it's that's
that's the good aspect of my mom that
was actually my great moment with my mom
but but that's a different story yeah so
I said to him would you would you be my
dad for my birthday it's coming up would
you get me a card or call me and and he
did he called from his hospital bed whoa
and he was about to the next day get a
feeding tube put in which is the end and
he's got his mask on I put my daughter
on his another empath and she's looking
at him she's four years old she cuz she
was even known FaceTime because I love
you Joe no view to Chloe
she travels my picture made him laugh to
look like a penis anyway and to make
that guy happy and his son happy that
that's going on just makes my life and
that's not something I'd played seventy
thousand people to Ison's
way better than that because this is
true this is absolutely there's nothing
between us except for like some
divineness and he just passed away a
couple days ago he did die and I know
that I did something good you know that
that I can go with it's better than the
awards it's better than the accolades
it's just that those moments and my
daughter by the way when the camera went
off she bawled she knew the guy was
gonna on the way you know she just gets
it at four years old so if I could pass
that on to the kids and that's what I do
now and that's those are my great
pleasure moments and usually something
to do with my wife or children my wife
just had this great surprise party for
me though they
blew me away you know and she found
friends and I didn't know she knew she
had found friends from childhood I mean
it was crazy I walked into this in my
eye the movie theater at this production
facility that I own and it's a big shoe
a really big shoe production TV and it's
just it was filled with people and I was
absolutely his blown off I couldn't even
speak or walk my legs were shaking
because that was true love you know I
think that's important the important
tone to end this on for a comics
listening is we can get into techniques
and like well how do you do this that
but it really is thinking of comedy in
terms of the impact you're making on
these people even if you are like in a
bar and there's like four people that
but those four people are there to laugh
yeah and treating the craft with that
sincerity and that hold it to that high
standard is well yeah you know what it
does it also gets the nerves out of it
because now it's not you don't have
performance anxiety literally like
you're doing sex you have that obviously
on stage you have much less of it if you
think I'm just being of service to
people hmm I'm going to hopefully catch
a smile and a laugh and a giggle and
take them away from what they're going
through there everybody goes through
issues in their lives and I can't tell
you the amount of times that's happened
with me too is like they're going
through this or a death and we were
gonna cancel because that and they show
up and then you are being of service to
them and that is you know George Bush
senior died today or yesterday and that
was one of the things about him that was
so admirable he's of service that was
his whole thing was being of service he
could disagree with his politics all you
want but that's that that's his legacy
now and what a great legacy to have in
comics really don't give themselves
credit for that is that we are healers
you know where the doctors where the
pharmacists or the pharmacy where we're
delivering this medicine to people and
if you can just clear away the ego and
the nerves and the fears and the worries
and the doubts and all that stuff and
the criticism if you can put that away
and just just keep it simple and give
them that
it takes you into a whole other space
and then the material happens and then
the the the style is born out of that
and then who you are on that stage is
consistent and have confidence and then
your confidence it's all rooted though
it has to be rooted in that it can't be
rooted in a goal that's up here or some
idea of what success is it can't be I or
trying to appease people or please
people it can't be that because if it's
based on them you're gonna fail because
if it's based on someone else's judgment
you're gonna fail hmm because everyone's
out to judge and criticize because they
don't want to look at themselves so if
you could just reflect back to them some
sort of a goodness like I was told my
friend was saying or kindness or love or
you're giving them something that
they're missing and a lot of comedians
don't look at it that way
you know it's a pretty selfish business
a lot of them yeah so if that's some
sort of a message that I could get
across along with my queefing well
that's like the the arc of the whole
show is like we took it way up here and
then we're like but be selfless and
self-aware and that'll then create with
over 150 of these you know that people
know what they're getting into okay yeah
yeah this is you know hope you know what
you're getting in prizes a story well as
soon I was like okay playboy it'll be
fine and then you're like oh and then
she quits and I was like oh whoa and she
gets in the bathroom I was like oh wow
this is going and you going think about
stopping the story and absolutely not
okay no I was gonna press like were you
talking like love-master this has been
great
I the fact you even willing to sit down
and do this not even knowing me but just
being like oh a fellow comic I'm I'm
down to support them doing something
positive so hopefully you'll send people
over to my party
yeah actually called Craig shoemaker can
I help you and spawn because I do like
helping people and if this helped you if
this helped anyone out there then I'm
good if one person says I'd be happy if
one person watched by the way oh they
will people watch somebody respond and
say I got this out of that I now know
what to do if I meet a queef or whatever
it is however I've helped you yeah
that's what I that's why I do that
podcast and it's real different I you
know I used to do the big radio type
thing with the you know screens and
microphones and big guests samuel
l.jackson all that and now it's like
I'll interview my accountant I went to
kindergarten with you no and it's more
you know how can we help one another
we're on this planet together for a
short time what can we do to support one
another that's what it's about so and
hopefully get some laughs as well well
before we get out of here is there
anything else you want the world to know
ah Sirius XM every Sunday huh it's an
eight o'clock Pacific to eleven o'clock
its p.m. and it's called Untied with
Craig shoemaker you see the shoe thing
there's a lot of shoes yeah Craig
shoemaker calm and follow me on the you
know Twitter I'm the love-master
Instagram I just hit 5,000 very excite
but they still won't verify me can't get
verified hey you verified I will yeah I
would hate you not on the blue check not
on the blue check I got all the other
ones but I don't have it on its day they
turn me down oh yeah Twitter's it's well
you know it's they're not looking for
you know someone from the past and
someone has this this career that's see
that's that vanity goal we were talking
about Craig there's an eagle yeah we
don't need that
well I only needed to extend my reach
that's the irony is I only reason I want
to be like famous or more people
following me is so I can help them or
let them know where I'm performing or
I'm a speaker as well I speak after
healing laughing helps calm as it's
called laughter heals the organization I
was spawned again out of being of
service my friend was dying they gave me
three months to live and he lived 15
years past that prognosis by adding a
lot of laughter to his life and a lot of
joy gives you reason to live mm-hmm
that's the other thing the comics deny
is what we actually are giving to people
is it's it's a new look on life and you
know turn away from all that there's so
much toxic out there it's like you know
let's get together and you know you're
like my brethren you know you're a
brother in this in this world right yeah
you know we're in the same business
mm-hmm and when you reached out to me on
fate on Twitter first thing I noticed is
you weren't following me yeah I just I
can't believe I'm doing this
now I'm not follow me I'm not active on
Twitter at all though but oh really I
really don't know not on Twitter soon as
you said yes though I was like research
mode that's what I do you must have
these interviews it's like I want people
to listen to hot breath and know okay I
could go listen to ten of their other
interviews or I can go to hot breath and
get all of them in one Wow so that's
been the goal of all of them well I've
only told that story to one other
podcast so that was it so we made it I'm
gonna cut it at never again my hot
breath exclusive yeah well Craig
shoemaker thank you so much for being a
hot breath you're welcome I hope it was
enjoyable it was great